[Music]
Clint you're on it click get off of it
pick it up the drone
I got Clint dude that was sweet I wanted
that again this here is an acro be drone
there's a tiny little racing drone with
a camera on it that lets me fly it as if
I am the drone now we decided to let our
imaginations get the best of us and
invented a pretty cool game here imagine
that these drones have tasers on them
Corinne and I are the guards of this
evil prison and our friends are the
convicts trying to escape if they run to
the end of the street they escape if we
touch them with the drones and
electrocute them before they get to the
end of the street they are recaptured
okay so I'm gonna go for Christian this
time because we wound up on Clint last
time yeah let it this time I'll go for
Sam all right putting it in front of him
and then they cut them off we have a
little duck in hide strategy we're gonna
dip and hide behind pillars we're not
just gonna go straight for the goal oh
we're going
keep down
the initial hide behind the pillar they
took off and then they just zoned in on
us
I had shots and I got Christian hates
children I just have to be more
aggressive that was the secret I really
feel like crowbars but really even the
stakes here you only have the shirt on
your back give me a chip I'll do a
sharpener plastic spoon I got put back
in jail and I escaped but now I came
back
[Music]
it's way easier to hit people together
come on I like your style I like your
song I met ran out of cars dude yeah man
those great that was really hard
I gotcha area right there at the
beginning stage of this data for today's
big exciting day I really wanted to get
a little tiny whoop drone so today we're
having one of the guys from newbie
drones come on over he's gonna set us up
with some tiny loops gotten got me
reminiscing about two years ago remember
this video Nick's a little spy drone
that I made on next door hey everyone
I'm upside down yeah that was that was
two years ago well two years ago like
this week this little drone is so out of
date that they've come out with a couple
versions since this one brand-new
state-of-the-art manhacks 2019 we wanted
to make a small brushed quad fly like a
full five inch brushless quad having
these smaller drones is a much greater
way to get new people into the Hobby cuz
if you have those big five-inch
carbon-fiber 500 ollar Massa is super
intimidating to a lot of new people
RV brain light the flight controller on
here we've got the radio receivers the
video transmitter built into here the
coolest thing that we've introduced on
this that no other micro drone on the
market or brushed drone on the market
has is called active braking if you want
to drop fast normally you wait for
momentum to slow the propeller down but
what the braking does is it physically
stops the motor so it just drops faster
so if you're like going through gaps and
stuff and you need to duck down or
excellently yeah it'll just not want it
upwards to rest
it'll physically slow it down so we set
up some rings we're gonna do some
practice flying with it by going through
a race course we just made in our own
studio how cool is that while you
believe in me hmm okay ready liftoff in
three two one thank you
there was a there was a ring underneath
that ring you wouldn't you would have
loved it
[Music]
skill my skills are coming back hey if
you want to know more about these check
them out on a youtube channel from
newbie drone link in the description
bonus ring
[Music]
that means we both have to have a double
killer one of us has to have a triple
kill at least yeah yeah let's do it
let's do it you guys again one last one
this is for real now that's the hole I'm
are I'm gonna survive yeah behind the
cars and like little bit max out has
come up here and hide behind
[Music]
done
I felt the finish line high-five but it
was just after the headshot already and
I've gotten pretty nimble if these guys
but these guys also started like
learning and how they could fly and how
do I avoid them so became like a really
even game it was really really fun and
they're just looking really like
satisfying about like it's a beaming
somebody at full-speed with your drone
so yeah probably more interesting
recommended to be a book and it was
awesome this book is perfect for it
brain is going to love this book I'm
really excited to recommend it to it I
really like opening people's eyes up to
like new things they really like I am
going to recommend you a book I haven't
told the read what this book is I told a
few weeks ago like when we do our next
audible integration I'm going to
recommend this to you because I think
you're really gonna like it it's a
science fiction book but the best
scientific sites are the ones where the
science is real it's called the
three-body problem oh dude
yes I'm already listening to it right
now I started it less but all my friends
think I specifically will enjoy this
book so I was like you know what fine
I'll get it I know nothing about it
I haven't even read this summary for you
don't know anything about for how
disappointed I am I'm also very excited
that you managed to have this
recommended to you four times without
anyone saying anything about it at this
point in the audible integration I was
planning on like hooking right in with
like a little synopsis of like what's
going on but he doesn't know anything
that's a cool position to be in reading
this book you go to audible.com slash
corridor crew or a free month of audible
or you can text toward our crew to five
hundred five hundred for a free month of
audible to listen to book okay now I
said that this is the part where I go
spoiler tags if you don't want if you're
gonna go listen to it right now pause
the video here go listen to it so
now girls coil with the three body
problem is hook you it into a little bit
the plot that I think makes this book
fascinating this is how Harley convinced
me to read the book there's three types
of civilizations type one civilization
harnesses all the energy of the planet
the type two harnesses all the energy of
a Sun and a type three harnesses all the
energy of a galaxy there's this
scientist in China and she discovers
that if she beams a strong enough radio
signal into the Sun the Sun will amplify
it thereby she can send a radio signal
out into the galaxy at the power of a
type two civilization it's the kind of
signal that could be heard by another
alien race I guess what happens now the
signal she gets says don't contact us
again don't do that again
my race is looking for another planet
and if we hear from you again we will
come to wipe you out
you got lucky in that the one who is
manning the listening station was me and
I'm a pacifist and I do not want to see
your planet destroyed so do not send
another message now if you read the book
you'll discover a little bit more about
this character and who she is because
the next thing she does
they send another message Carmichael
what do you think are you enticed yeah I
get freaking out yeah yeah yeah here's
another interesting thing is written by
a Chinese author so the story tellings a
little bit different than like an
American book for example rather than
like hooking you from the beginning and
just dropping hook after hook this kind
of starts writing and it's just like the
world starts I feel like American books
are kind of like the YouTube videos of
fiction it's like if they don't hook you
in that first chapter of the book you're
putting the book down and never opening
it again but a good foundation is a good
long-term investment wait
Bren can you do the autumn I'll call it
this time oh yeah sure you can get this
book for free if you get a 30-day trial
through audible.com slash court or crew
or I guess you can text 500 500 to court
the next court our crew - 500 500 right
now at the new new year a new rim you
can make resolution to listen to more
cool stories so you can tell your
friends about them and be the cool guy
who comes up with new story
pretty Elsa feeling like they haven't
heard of yet that was my resolution do
you I've got like over 1500 hours into
audible right now they have books
recorded originally for audible from
journalists actors theater professionals
oh and three body probably can hear them
pronounce the Chinese names correctly
but uh the the narrator is also the
narrator of another book I eventually
want to talk about called off to be the
Wizard